all right welcome to the third and final
step of how to solve a 4x4 Rubik's cube
revenge at this point you should have a
cube that resembles a mixed-up 3x3 cube
where all of the centers have been
positioned correctly and also all of the
edges have been paired up with their
complementary piece now I am going to
display both the algorithms from solving
a 3x3 cube which I use to solve the 4x4
and also the new algorithms were going
to use to fix parity however I'm not
going to reteach the 3x3 algorithms in
this video so if you don't know exactly
how to use them you should refer to my
3x3 tutorial on the playlist on my page
when using my method for solving the 4x4
there are basically only three total
parity cases that you need to worry
about and the first one we already
learned at the end of the second step so
let's go on to solve the cube as a 3x3
now basically you should already know
how to solve a 3x3 so I'm not going to
explain in detail some steps which
involve basic 3x3 moves okay so for
purposes of solving the 4x4 cube as a
3x3 these double edged pieces here can
be considered the same as these
single-edged pieces on the 3x3 also this
4 piece center can be considered the
same as a single piece Center on a 3x3
as well so the only thing that stops us
from solving the 4x4 completely as a 3x3
are going to be the parity cases which
I'm going to show you how to correct in
this video so I like to place the white
as my bottom and the yellow as my top
knowing that I can then go on to solve
the bottom white cross as I would with a
3x3 so let me do that so what I'm going
to do is make the bottom white cross
so now you can see I have a cross on the
bottom that is comparable to having a
white cross on the bottom of a 3x3 each
of these dead jiz have been paired up
with its side Center and it's also with
its bottom Center so then what I do is I
place each of these corner pieces down
with its respective dead piece which is
basically comparable to a middle edge
piece on a 3x3 so let me go ahead and do
that as well so there I have one placed
to place another one which is there
here's the third one and for the last
one I have placed it here so now I have
placed all three bottom layers of the
4x4 this is basically the same as
placing the first two layers of a 3x3 so
now what we want to do is to solve the
top cross okay so before trying to solve
the top cross we have to first see
whether or not the cube has a parity
error if you do have a parity error at
this point you will have a cube that
looks very similar to either of the two
cubes I have in front of me now if it
doesn't and it looks something more like
one of the four following patterns here
where it has a single dot a horizontal
line a backwards L or if it has the
cross already then you do not have a
parity error and you can basically get
from any of these steps directly to this
one without having to fix parity in this
case if you do have a cube like one of
the two however you basically want to
get a cube that looks like this one so
you want to change this so that it looks
like this one in this case what we're
going to be able to do from this step is
to flip this edge pair over in that case
we would have a complete cross so let me
first show you how to change this one if
you have it into a 3/4 cross as I call
it that basically just
one edge pair flipped so what we're
first going to do is we're going to hold
the cube so that we have this two by
three block basically horizontal and
also so that we have a missing pair on
the right side so we basically want this
two by three block all the way to the
left horizontal on the top face then
we're going to perform the following
move that is also performed in the
fourth step of the 3x3 tutorial so that
move is front clockwise top clockwise
right clockwise top counterclockwise
right counterclockwise and front
counterclockwise so now you'll see that
we have basically the same pattern here
where we have a three 3/4 cross and
basically this edge piece has been
flipped over so now we're going to have
to memorize a longer algorithm which
basically flips this edge piece over and
I'd say this is probably one of the
longer algorithms you're going to have
to memorize in order to solve the 4x4
and also the 5x5 as well so the
algorithm that we're going to have to
memorize is first of all we want to have
this this flipped edge pair we want to
have it right in front here on the top
face then we're going to perform the
following algorithm in order to flip it
over and finish the cross so we're going
to do both right layers 180 degrees the
back face 180 degrees the up face 180
degrees both left faces clockwise the up
face 180 degrees both right faces
counterclockwise the up face 180 degrees
both right faces clockwise then we're
going to do the up face 180 degrees the
front face 180 degrees both right faces
clockwise the front face 180 degree
these both left faces counterclockwise
the back face 180 degrees and we're
going to do both right faces 180 degrees
so what you should see at this point
is that you have a completed cross so
what we're going to do now is basically
finish the top face so that it is one
solid yellow color okay so at this point
you should have a yellow cross on the
top face of the cube because we correct
the previous parity error in which that
one edge piece was flipped we can now
solve the entire yellow face exactly
like a 3x3 so you should know how to
complete the top face of the cube which
is explained in detail in the fifth step
of my 3x3 tutorial I will provide the
algorithms however so you can see which
algorithm I am using but you should know
how to position the cube correctly
already so what I'm going to do now is
to solve the entire top face the
algorithm I'm going to use is right
clockwise top clockwise right counter
clockwise top clockwise right clockwise
top 180 and right counter clockwise I'm
then going to use that same algorithm
again to complete the top face so right
clockwise top clockwise right counter
clockwise top clockwise right clockwise
top 180 and then right counter clockwise
okay so now since the entire top face is
complete we want to position the top
corners so we look around the top layer
until we find two adjacent top corners
which have the same color as we do here
this is now denoted as the back face so
setting this as the back face we then
perform another algorithm which
corresponds with step six in my tutorial
so that algorithm is Right
counterclockwise front clockwise right
counter clockwise back 180 degrees right
clockwise front counter clockwise right
counter clockwise back 180 degrees
and right 180 degrees so what we'll see
in this case is that we have one solid
side here and another solid side on the
opposite side so this goes on the green
side and this goes on the blue side so
we'll flip it 180 degrees okay so now
what you'll see is that the two top edge
pieces here the two top edge pairs have
been flip-flopped this goes on the red
side and this goes on the purple side so
the algorithm which we're going to have
to know in order to flip-flop these two
edge pairs is the following inside right
face 180 degrees up face 180 degrees
inside right face again 180 degrees both
up faces 180 degrees inside right face
180 degrees the both up faces 180
degrees and then we're going to rotate
just the top face 180 degrees so if you
completed that move correctly you should
have a completed cube you might also
have to perform the step 7 part of my
tutorial which you perform the Allan
algorithm as well all right so I hope
that this tutorial was helpful and
allows you to better understand the
methods for solving the 4x4 cube as
always you can send me a message on
YouTube or post questions or comments on
any of the steps for solving the 4x4 I'm
also thinking about making a tutorial
for the 5x5 as well so please let me
know if you like the style of this
tutorial so I could determine if I
should make a 5x5 tutorial in a similar
way thank you all for watching as well